PROFESSOR: We're going to start
with the discussion portion,
just to give a little
context to the reading
that we've been doing.
I am a big fan of having
designers think about artifacts
through the lens of
criticism every now and then,
and I have a background
in games criticism.
I did that for about
10 years in parallel
with my illustrious
academic career
when I was still in Sweden.
So I also teach games
criticism to unrelated students
here at MIT.
And when it comes
how to do critiques
of interactive
artifacts, there's
still a lot of uncertainty
about how to best do it,
and how and why it needs to
be different from criticism
of film or literature,
or any of these things
that we've been doing
analysis of since for it.
And one of the
approaches is a method
called interaction criticism.
It's not specifically
designed for games
or playful interactive
experiences,
but just interactive,
non-production-related
artifacts in general.
And the things we've
been reading today
is, one, from the originator
himself, Jeff Bardzell.
So we're trying to give an
introduction to the method
and the theory behind it.
And the other one is him and
two other interaction design
and media studies
scholars trying
to apply interaction criticism
to a particular cultural
artifact, and through
different senses
and seeing what
they come up with,
and whether that's
interesting and fruitful.
So with that said,
let's start with the one
called Interaction Criticism,
an Introduction to the Practice,
and put keywords
on the whiteboard.
OK, so maybe we
want to start with--
it doesn't matter
which one of these--
but subjective.
Who put that there?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
PROFESSOR: OK, hello.
AUDIENCE: OK, so one of
the interesting things
from this paper I
noticed is that when
you talk about criticism, it's
someone's judgment on a thing,
and that judgment can
often be subjective.
And so a lot of the
discussion in this paper
is reconciling the clearly
subjective nature of criticism,
but in a way that,
they say, is judgments
that are subjective,
but non-perspectival.
Is that how you pronounce that?
PROFESSOR: I think they
probably just made up the word,
so it's your call.
AUDIENCE: I know what they mean,
which ties into perspectives.
But the idea is
that the judgment
itself comes from, they focus
on critics that are experts
in their fields, and the
judgments themselves come
from experts who know about many
similar types of interaction, I
would say.
I don't want to say games,
because it doesn't say games.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, no, it
clearly sort of skirts.
So just to interrupt
a little bit.
Specifically, [INAUDIBLE]
is one of the people who
are applying it in
the second paper,
has said that the only
professional practice
of interaction criticism
is games criticism.
We don't have any other sort
of interactive art form that's
sort of strong enough
to have people get paid
to do this kind of criticism.
So for better or
worse, that's kind
of what we have to
look to as an example.
But especially
Bardzell, I think,
it's very critical to how games
criticism is currently done,
and thinks that
there's a lot to learn
from other critical
practices, and he
comes from a background
in those areas.
So yeah, he's not going
to talk about games,
but they're sort of
hovering in there.
AUDIENCE: And he also
mentions, I guess,
also that they're not talking
about amateur critics,
like the people who go on Amazon
or on Steam and rate whatever
they want to rate.
Because that could be
subjective but very
based on that person's
own experience
without trying to see
things in a broader context.
PROFESSOR: So to
begin with, what
do we think of this
idea of a somehow
more rigorous objectivity?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that's [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Reflections on that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I put aesthetics.
And so it's very similar to what
we're talking about right now,
which I find that, throughout
the readings that we've
been doing, design is in the
middle of science and art.
So a lot of times
there's a temptation
to do things very
scientifically,
but that fails when aesthetics
come into play, because they're
very subjective.
And so that's why
we need criticism.
That's what they're
kind of saying.
PROFESSOR: Right, so we don't
have a choice but to rely
on our subjectivity , because
there's no other rules given
to us for how to evaluate
this kind of stuff.
It's not just describable.
That misses some
important point.
By the way, I would say
that Bardzell doesn't
think of design as something
in between science and art,
but rather something
distinctly different from both.
So he wants it to
be its own thing.
But yes, clearly, all
the sources that he
is borrowing on
when he's creating
this method coming from one
or the other, so there's that.
But yes, and those were the
word pair I was thinking of,
when I said we could
start in either end.
But then what goes
into this expertise
that he talks about how?
Do we justify that someone's
subjective opinion of something
is more, weighs heavier
than someone else's?
What makes up for the
difference between a critic
and someone on Amazon?
AUDIENCE: Well,
knowledge about the field
and having a very
broad experience,
and I guess the people
who you are critiquing,
or who are reading
the critiques,
knowing that you have
that broad experience.
Someone that got an
espresso machine off Amazon
might leave a terrible
review being like, oh,
it didn't just instantly
make me coffee, one star,
because they don't understand
how the espresso machine works,
or what the different
grades might be,
or how any of the different
pieces of the process work.
Whereas the critic who will
have value behind what they say
understands the whole
field, and how this helps,
and what place it has,
and what the context
of it, and like other good
works in the field are.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So a good example,
so this is one
of those things that are
often highlighted in design
educations, and I probably have
said the word a couple of times
during the semester as well.
So the way we educate
ourselves in design
is often looking
at what has been
established as good examples.
And they're good just because
someone decided they were good.
There's nothing in
nature determining
that they're good other than
ourselves and our community,
but that has an important
role, I would say,
within games criticism.
There's nothing that
speaks as loud as having
this almost data-based knowledge
of the history of video games
when you get
interviewed for writing
for a website or a journal,
or something, magazine,
I should say.
That's what they
question you on,
do you know about this
and that, and that
is the most important
criteria for whether you're
going to get the job or not.
AUDIENCE: It's, do
you know the history?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And that is one of the things
that Bardzell would say
is the problem with
games criticism.
What do you think
could be potentially
an issue with that
kind of filter
for who gets to be a critic?
AUDIENCE: I'm not playing games
to know the history of games.
PROFESSOR: Right.
But yeah, they actually expect
you to not just know it,
but have played it.
So the most well-played,
if we can make up a word
based on well-read, so the
most well-played people
tend to get the jobs as critics.
But is there a
problem with that?
And what would that--
and now we're sort of
off the paper already,
but we'll get back to it.
AUDIENCE: There's sort of a
disconnect between someone
who has played a lot
of games, with someone
who has played no games.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
But, yes.
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean,
it was a good point.
It would be difficult for the
folks who played a lot of games
to be able to even translate
their thoughts to someone who's
never played those games.
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's
what you were saying.
So yes, you will be a little
bit like, let's say, a jazz
critic that just listens to--
AUDIENCE: Coltrane.
PROFESSOR: Well, not even--
Coltrane is for the masses.
They're beyond Coltrane.
They might be talking above
the heads of most people,
so there's a disconnect
with the audience.
So that might just make
the criticism very insular
and not really sort
of reach the audience
who might be interested
in evaluation
of these cultural artifacts.
So that, I think, is
a very good point.
Anything else along those lines?
AUDIENCE: So what a
fix to accommodate
for that be to ask
for a writing sample
and actually judge
whether or not
that person can communicate at
multiple levels of an audience?
PROFESSOR: Actually,
the most important skill
is not being a very
knowledgeable gamer,
but being a good writer.
Because without that
skill, you get nowhere.
And no one's going to
read you, basically,
because you write like
a robot, or something.
AUDIENCE: Actually, I want to
say even the converse might
actually be true, of trying to
look for people who don't sort
of toe the line of
traditional game criticism
and become a lot more sought
after and invited now.
So folks who are
expressly stating opinions
from or analyzing
games are coming up
from the lens of
something that's
not like traditional
games criticism.
It seems, in this
click-hungry media
landscape, seemed actually to be
a lot more interesting to read.
So they're good
writers, and they're
bringing a new perspective.
PROFESSOR: And I think
for, among other things,
one important reason is
that there is an existing
hegemony around the field of
what a good game is and should
be that may be based on
assumptions about gender
and culture that
should be questioned.
It might be white men writing
for white men, basically,
of a certain age.
And if we think,
especially back in time,
playing video games,
having grown up
playing all these games
on all these consoles
implies a very
strong privilege when
it comes to finance,
your family's finances,
for instance.
Consoles used to
be, I mean, they
used to cost the same
as they cost today.
Games used to cost the
same as they cost today,
but that was a lot more
money in the '80s and '90s
than it is now.
So someone who had access to all
of the existing home consoles
was probably a rich kid.
So those were the ones who
became reviewers and decided
what a good game is.
So there's something about
looking to those good examples
that could also need some
questioning, and we might need
to break with those
traditions and look
at other potential values
in interactive artifacts
as the ones that
we are creating,
those that are maybe
more inclusive,
or taking other
skillsets to heart,
rather than just excellent
hand-eye coordination,
or whatever it is that
makes a good gamer.
AUDIENCE: Before we leave
this, just one more angle
I want to bring up, which is,
even if you were expressly
looking for people
who state that they
have a long history with games
and can bring up this catalog,
which history, right?
Because in games, or
even digital games,
and extend it out to
non-digital games,
to board games or
tabletop and sports,
then it's like each
country, each region
has its own history,
and people consider
different things canonical.
So a lot of American white
men writing for white boys
pretty much have a
fairly lacking experience
of Eastern Bloc
games, even games
that were released in
Asia, for instance.
Only a few Japanese games are
sort of re-released in America.
And they think that's
all of Japan, right?
And it's like, no, that's not--
that's part of Japan,
and not even all of Asia.
So that would be an example.
That will be another
problem, is that you
assume that a long
history implies
a comprehensive history.
But no one really has a
comprehensive specific history
with the entire world's
history of games.
PROFESSOR: And
that criticism has
been put towards design
studies, as well.
I mean, we are reading
three white men
of a somewhat certain
age here today.
So they are, to some
extent, myopic, as well,
when it comes to cultural
values in these artifacts.
And I was thinking maybe
we can get back on track
by inviting whoever put
perspectives on there.
AUDIENCE: It was me.
They were talking in this
article about the four
perspectives of,
was it the designer,
the user, where they, like the--
AUDIENCE: Artifact and society?
Artifact and society?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It was sort of what I
was talking about before.
It's like someone who
is very well-played
is going to have a different
interaction with the artifact,
compared to someone who does
not play a lot of games.
You have to consider a lot
of different perspectives,
and it's very easy to get stuck.
And the idea is, you
get stuck in one.
A creator can't see
their own problems,
a lot of the time, which
is why you need criticism.
And the criticiser doesn't
have the perspective
that the creator does.
PROFESSOR: So
that's, I mean, one
of the reason we
have criticism is
to try to improve whatever
field we are critiquing.
So it's supposed to be
a help for the designers
to see things that they can't
see themselves, as well.
And what I would do, if
this was a longer class,
I would have you write up
critiques of each other's work.
But we're just, we have
so much work to do,
so we don't quite
have time for it.
So I don't want to sort
of burden you with that.
But it is a very interesting
exercise, because you instantly
see that people see things in
the thing you've been making
that you didn't see
yourself, and you
thought you saw all
of it, because you're
so engaged with it.
This is also something
that breaks with tradition
of old-school
literary theory, which
used to be very heavily
focused on artifacts.
So you wanted to
just look at the text
and see what the meaning
of the text really is.
It comes from religious
studies of trying
to figure out what the
Bible is telling us to do,
or something like that.
But that was what the
academic study of literature
used to be, as well,
what is the author's
intentions with this
text, and try to sort
of just reverse engineer.
Nowadays, we read, and we
can talk about all kinds
of artifacts as texts.
It seems a little weird
to do that, call a game
a text, for instance.
But if you think of the Latin
origin of the word, which
textera basically means
more like a texture,
like something that's
woven together,
then it's easier to
think, talk and think
about things as texts other
than written words on a page.
So when we interpret texts, now,
through interaction criticism,
for instance, we very
much take into account
the context it is used in.
Because we think
that there isn't just
one meaning of a
cultural artifact.
It actually changes
meaning depending
on who is interacting with it,
and under which circumstances.
And that is something that has
changed literature studies, as
well, the idea of it
being someone encountering
the text, which you can hear
in the name of reader response
theory for instance,
which is, it's
not just about what Shakespeare
meant when he wrote the text.
It's about how a reader now can
respond to a text like Hamlet
that is of interest.
So this is very much based
on that tradition of,
we are doing a reading not
just of the artifact itself,
but the context of use and
the identity of the user,
and so forth.
OK, so what you have left,
let's talk about a little bit
about balance.
AUDIENCE: So I
put that up there,
and it was mostly
about, he was talking
about how, with the
criticisms, there's somewhat
trying to strike this balance
between historical context,
cultural significance, and
technical descriptions,
and how do you, so how do you
balance the different elements
that you should be looking at?
Because these are
all different lenses
that a different person might
evaluate through differently,
especially based on
what field they're
in that is not interaction
design, or interaction
criticism for design.
But scientific design is very
much of the, how this was done,
or [INAUDIBLE],, how was
this done, empirical facts.
And so there's a lot
about different ways
to focus those designs, to
focus the criticism based
on the different
aspects that you can
be trying to evaluate through.
PROFESSOR: And that is
what, I think, for Bardzell,
that is one of the
things that creates
the need for
interaction criticism.
Because that's somewhat alien to
someone who is doing criticism
of movies or literature.
To them, it's perfectly
fine to look at it as just
something that is being
evaluated for its aesthetics,
end of story.
Well, when we evaluate
a game, let's say
you're driving a
car in the game,
and the steering
works very poorly.
It's just, there's a
usability issue there
that's very similar to
when we evaluate cars.
So if the steering
is bad, that's
going to affect the quality
of this kind of artwork thing,
but it's a very sort of
usability-centered thing.
So games and
interactive artifacts
live in this weird space where
these things come together,
and all of them matter.
So some of it is just
matter-of-factly,
this steering wheel is bad,
while some of it is like,
the scenery of the
car ride in this game
evokes emotions, a lot of that.
So to me, it's what makes
interaction design cool,
because it has all of these
very different qualities to it,
and they can be
foregrounded or sort of
be more part of the periphery.
But they all have to work in
concert for an interaction
design for the unity, or organic
unity of it, as Bardzell says,
to click.
OK, so I guess we
just have framework.
So let's do that one as well,
so you don't feel left out.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I put framework,
because this article
is a lot about developing
a way to criticize
interactive material.
And I think it mentions how it's
about developing skills that
enable people to think
about interaction.
And so that's why I thought
framework was a good word.
PROFESSOR: Right.
I mean, that's what
he's doing here.
So it's a somewhat
ambitious project
to sort of establish,
starting the establishment
of a framework that goes outside
of the tradition of HCI, which
is much more usability-focused,
on and without losing
those qualities, still capturing
the things that sort of fall
through the net of what
that type of criticism
or that type of evaluation
captures in an experience.
OK, are we ready
for paper number
two, looking at the
actual application
of interaction criticism?
AUDIENCE: I've got a question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: What's
the difference--
so there are-- correct me if I'm
wrong-- there are car critics,
right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: There are people who
review cars professionally.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: What's the
difference, would that
be considered a form of
interaction criticism
of design?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So I think that, to
Bardzell, it doesn't.
AUDIENCE: It's not.
PROFESSOR: No.
Because the focus is so much
on the usability aspects.
AUDIENCE: Not on,
like, the interior.
PROFESSOR: Right.
I mean, we do sometimes
see that kind of approach,
where someone is sort
of trying to focus more
on the experience of a car,
or something like that.
And that's when it starts
coming closer to that line.
So he talks about,
not in this paper
but in another sort
of parallel paper,
he talks about interior
design and things like that,
that there's definitely
touch points.
And when we start talking about
stuff like the sound design,
what sound a car door
makes when it closes,
that's very carefully
designed nowadays.
And that is part of the
aesthetic experience
of the car.
AUDIENCE: So just going back
to balance, there could be a--
one-dimensional, might
be two, three dimensions,
but there's aesthetics
on one side,
and usability, technical
details on the other.
And car critics fall much closer
to the technical usability
side.
Interior design falls much more
towards the aesthetic side.
PROFESSOR: Right.
But interior design, so
maybe it's not a line.
Because interior design,
interior design critique
is still very far from
traditional literary theory.
So maybe it's some
kind of weird polygon.
I don't think it's
even a triangle.
But yeah, it's a field
where he sort of tries
to visualize some of the--
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah,
the seven values.
PROFESSOR: Right, but maybe
not necessarily all of them.
I don't think he tries to
be comprehensive of what
that space looks like.
But I feel like the
paper is still written
as a critique of HCI study.
So that's the one he
wants to focus on,
like you guys are missing
things when you decide what gets
accepted to Chi, or something.
AUDIENCE: But that's
the context of why
he's publishing it, right, is
interacting with computers,
in part, is the magazine,
or is the journal.
And I'm curious about
that other people
that you're describing,
because you're
talking about interior design.
I'm thinking there's got to be
architectural criticism that's
a fairly well-established
field, and the only difference
that I see between what he's
arguing in architectural design
is the use of computers in
his what he's describing.
We're talking about concrete,
and steel, and wood,
and other kinds of materials,
but everything else,
architecture is just as
interactive as anything
built by interaction.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The outside of academia
professional core
of architectural
critics is very small.
So I don't think it reaches--
so [INAUDIBLE] said it's
only the games that really
have an established core of
professional critics outside
of academia.
And I think it
means he's thinking
that the architectural
critics are [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: I mean, that's
perfectly fine to argue that it
should be a larger thing.
PROFESSOR: Right.
And I also think that, when
we look towards architecture,
we're also seeing
this transition where
they try to focus
more on experience
and different perspectives,
rather than saying
that the quality of the
architecture is in the artifact
itself.
It used to be, if you look
at architecture education,
the good examples
was very much about,
like, this is good
because this and this
and this, rather
than talking about,
it's good from this perspective,
because this and that.
So there is that movement
within architectural criticism,
as well, to go, maybe--
I usually have architecture
students in the other classes,
and they always giggle
when I mention Gary.
Because within architecture,
he's seen as kind of a fad,
and we have a big wonky
example of that here on campus.
So that sort of focus
on the beautiful shapes
and all of that, it's a little
old school now in architecture,
and now it's more about,
how livable is this,
or how well can you work
in that weird bubble.
And it turns out not very well.
AUDIENCE: Just as literary
criticism and, no doubt,
interactive design
criticism is going
to go through these waves of
different styles of criticism,
and they don't
invalidate the old ones.
They just add to how we
look at the same thing.
PROFESSOR: Right, but they
might invalidate decisions
to hire certain architects
to do certain flagship
buildings on campus,
or something like that.
I don't think that
choice would be made--
AUDIENCE: Based on criticism?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, well
based on, oh, yeah,
that was maybe cool because
the methods were new,
and they're not so new anymore.
So yeah, it's a little bit of
that hype thing has done away
from, oh, we can actually
have computers design curves
that we couldn't
calculate before
if they would be load-bearing.
AUDIENCE: Certainly, at MIT,
because we have an architecture
department and
architecture faculty,
criticism must influence
the choice of architects.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I think for one
thing, the MIT campus has
a lot more examples of
high-profile architectural
buildings than almost
any other campus,
because we have such a prominent
architecture department,
and through a series of
styles that don't necessarily
always fit together.
AUDIENCE: They don't.
A scrapbook.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
very much a scrapbook.
Anyway, that's a little
bit of a tangent.
So any other thoughts
on the Bardzell paper,
before we leave?
We're good?
OK, now let's do
keywords for a second.
OK, so I'm tempted to--
we had perspectives in the last
paper, and now we have lenses.
So maybe we can
start with lenses,
and they can describe what
the difference between a lens
and a perspective is.
AUDIENCE: So I specifically said
lenses, because perspectives
can mean personal perspectives.
You might have a very
different perspective of a game
than I do, because of
our personal backgrounds,
and likes, and whatnot.
But the lenses are more,
you're viewing this
through a
performance-based lens,
you're viewing this through
an interaction-based lens,
you're viewing this through the
context of a particular thing.
So perspectives can be
that, but it can also
be through your self, or
through how we use it,
or how certain
people might feel.
There's why I
specifically said lenses.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And I think, yeah, that's
spot-on, what they mean,
as well.
It's more like, I,
as a person, choose
to put on this
lens, a little bit
like you might switch
the lens for your camera
for a particular purpose.
OK, so did you have more
to say about your word?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So one of the big
things, as he's
talking about in this paper, is
how through different lenses,
the same thing can be viewed in
very different lights, or very
different ways, or come out very
differently in the criticism.
So he has the three different
criticism points of Maeve,
and is saying at
the end about how,
just because of these lenses,
the criticism of either
the interaction, the
performance, or the users
comes through differently.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think we should be able to
jump to almost any of the words
from there.
Let's maybe do interface first.
AUDIENCE: OK, so one of
my favorite sentences
in this article is that
form and content, interface
and information are inseparable.
And interface describes
how you interact
with the information that's
being presented to you,
and can greatly influence how
you interpret the information
that is presented to you.
They use, as an
example, I think it
was like a Java applet,
the word synonym finder,
this visual synonym finder.
I actually have a memory
of using this way back
in the day, the
early internet days,
of having it in this
bubble on the screen.
PROFESSOR: Early
world wide web base.
Internet is, you weren't around.
AUDIENCE: No, that's true.
That's what I meant.
Back in the days when
dial-up was a thing.
So I remembered that
experience, and so that was a--
the way that they frame it is
that experience of seeing words
and connection to
other words, and how
they relate to each other, and
being able to make these hops,
these may small hops, but end
up very far away from the word
that you started.
It makes language more
fluid, instead of like,
when you read a dictionary,
which has basically the same
information-- it contains
words and what they mean--
but it's presented in this
very logical, strict manner.
And similarly, with
this Maeve project,
you can think of
it as, oh, you just
have a collection of
files on different--
I think it's architectural,
this architectural project--
and you could click through
the files, or something,
have it on your computer screen.
But now they've turned it
into, basically, the users
of the system are performers.
What they choose to view gets
presented on a larger screen,
and they also get to see
how they're, like the cards
that they choose, relate to
things that other users are
choosing.
And this adds like
a social element,
a performative element,
and greatly changes
the way users can see how
each of these different cards
are, like they can actually
see more direct comparisons
and [INAUDIBLE].
So yeah, I [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, no.
Yeah, that's a
pretty powerful idea.
I think that it's not just
a quantitative difference
between different interfaces.
Another example would be
the physical typewriter
versus a word processor.
It's not just that the word
processor makes it easier
or faster to produce text.
We actually write
different things.
We think differently because
of this word processor
working in a certain way
than we used to think
when we had typewriters.
It's somehow changed
the world, and not just,
again, quantitatively,
but qualitatively.
People understand
texts and themselves
differently because of
this change of interface.
And this is just an
extension of that,
where we can understand
another data set completely
differently, depending on how
it is, not just presented to us,
but how we are allowed
to interact with it.
We will get back a
little bit to the idea
of being able to interact
with ideas next week,
when we're going to
start thinking about how
to disseminate the
knowledge that we're
generating in this class.
But I leave that there, for now.
I'm just going to
keep going here.
Distinction?
AUDIENCE: That was me.
The article was talking a lot
about how, increasingly, we're
splitting form and function,
and the ideas, the information
you want to convey to
the user and the way
that you do that are
considered differently,
and that that's
not a good thing.
It's like the idea of using
the lenses and the interface,
the stuff we've been talking
about, to mix the two,
because it's often
more successful.
You want to get the--
I'm just going to use
play a game-- you want
to get plot information
across to the player,
because it's a
story, but you also
want them to have
fun while doing it
and interact with the story.
So they were talking
about the idea
of performative experiences.
PROFESSOR: That goes very much
along the same lines of what
we were talking about, with
the interfaces, I think.
Let's keep on going,
the information.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The reason I put
that down was also
because of the
way the paper said
that interface and
information are inseparable.
PROFESSOR: I see you've all
caught on to the same idea.
I guess that is the big
takeaway from this paper.
And it's all, I think, the same
sort of criticism of, maybe,
specifically in software
engineering, for reasons
of dealing with complexity,
we divided different aspects
of these artifacts
into different roles,
and different teams.
And it turns out it's
kind of a suboptimization,
because it all has
to work in concert,
or it's not going
to be successful.
And sort of trying
to find a way back
to ideas of the designer and
the one actually manufacturing
something being the
same person, where
they have full control over
all aspects of it, to how can
we have complex development
with a lot of people involved,
and still not lose touch of the
organic unity of the thing, how
it all relates to each other.
Did performance
have anything else
to add that hasn't
come up already?
I feel like we're beating
this to the ground.
AUDIENCE: More information?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes, if there was something
that you felt hasn't been--
AUDIENCE: Well,
I guess we didn't
talk about the communication
aspect that was in the paper,
about how the user is in
the loop of application,
but also now, with
like social media,
you're also communicating
things to other people.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah.
And performance, did you
have something to add?
AUDIENCE: I don't know if
I have much more to add.
But I just thought it was
really interesting, because I,
or at least when I'm
designing, I think of my users
like in a vacuum, kind of.
Or if it's a
multiplayer experience,
then I think of them
working together,
but I had never thought of
someone being performing,
as a user.
And so I just thought
that was interesting,
an interesting takeaway for
me and my design endeavors.
PROFESSOR: Right.
I don't think it's just pointing
towards the importance of user
testing, but also trying to
challenge your own assumptions,
as you're having people
test your artifact.
Again, the things we
create are our babies,
and we tend to sort of cradle
them a little hard sometimes,
and we don't want-- we
want people to get how
we intended them to be used.
And then we might be
less open to seeing where
the users or the
participants actually
subvert our
intentions, but still
make interesting use
of the artifacts,
and that is something
that we could actually
benefit from, from allowing
and allowing ourselves to see.
And I think just
one example was when
I was talking to game designers
here in Boston about designing
co-op games, and I was
making a case that they often
make a less interesting
experience for player 2
than for player 1, I had a
guy come up to me afterwards
saying, I've made co-op
games for 10 years
and never thought of myself as
anything other than player 1.
So if you're making those
kinds of experiences,
at least try out
the different roles
that you are
designing for, and not
make assumptions
that, well, the expert
or the highly-skilled
person is always
going to be in this
role, and that fits me,
so I'm always going
to try out that role.
Because when you try out
the role of player 2,
you might find that it's much
less either fun or interesting
than you intended for it to
be, just as one brief example.
AUDIENCE: I also found
it really interesting
how they connected performance
to social media platforms.
Because that is an interactive
experience that isn't a game,
but some people
think it's a game.
How many likes do you have?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it
can be gamed, for sure.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, or
like World of Warcraft,
where you create this alternate
persona, or you put on this,
you perform.
You perform the role of knight
elf priest, or whatever,
or you perform the role of
a popular figure on Twitter
who talks about puppies,
and that sort of thing.
And I hadn't thought of
it as performance before,
but it really
comes down to that.
And depending on
how much community
aspect you have inside of
whatever you're developing,
it seems like there's more
of a performance aspect.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
There's a lot of opportunity
for designing your own role
or identity online than you
have in offline performance.
I mean, we're still
performing a certain role
when we're at work versus
at home, and so on.
But you have a lot more
variables to tweak, I think,
online.
And it's just something
that's inherently in you.
It's not something that
we have any experience
from before this century.
We just didn't have
massively multi experienced
virtual environments,
and now we do.
So we're struggling a little
bit with how to design for them
and make sense of
them, but no one else
is going to do it for us.
So you are the ones
to solve these issues.
Congratulations.